the murder of an American woman and her
Australian boyfriend in Canada could be
connected to other crimes along a remote
highway investigators have released this
sketch of a person of interest in the
killings of China DS and Lucas Fowler
Nikki petit shows us why police are not
ruling out a connection with two other
incidents it's a love story that's ended
tragically Stephen Fowler is sending a
desperate plea for information
surrounding the deaths of his son Lucas
and Lucas's girlfriend North Carolina
native China DS two young people who had
everything ahead of them tragically
murdered the young couple was wrapping
up a two-week long road trip through
northern British Columbia when they were
found shot to death last Monday by their
broken-down van newly released
surveillance video shows the couple
hugging at a gas station two days before
their bodies were discovered police also
released this sketch of a person they
say was seen talking to Fowler about 300
miles south in the same province several
days later police found a burning car
belonging to two missing Canadian
teenagers during that investigation the
body of an older man was found a little
over a mile away police released this
sketch of the victim asking for help
identifying him this isn't you know it's
unusual to have two major investigations
undergoing of this nature in northern BC
at the same time and so we recognize
that there is a possibility of that base
could be linked 48 hours has previously
reported on a notorious remote stretch
of road near these crimes dubbed the
highway of tears at least 18 women in
the last 40 years have disappeared or
been found murdered along it as
authorities investigate whether any of
these new cases might be related the
victims friends and family want answers
why he was such a friendly guy he was
going to people he didn't even know it's
surreal Fowler's father is a police
officer in Australia and has two
colleagues with him in Canada police
haven't determined the cause of death of
a man found near the missing teens car
and whether there was any connection but
given this highways history it certainly
makes you wonder wow 18 women
along that highway over the tap does 40
years you said 40 years yes yes we have
to wait and see very suspicious and very
concerning but we don't know thank you
very much Niki